after a contentious Senate sessioned a
lot to legalize the recreational use of
marijuana crashed into a war the votes
scheduled for early Tuesday afternoon
finally happened late into the night as
lawmakers scrambled to reach a deal but
in the end there was no majority for it
we have given a fight with argument for
the last four years here and today I
just want to give thanks to all who
helped us get this far this fight
continues to advance the votes show it
it is the end of the road for a bill
that promised to legalize the recreation
in marijuana Market in a country
devastated by Decades of war and drugs
outside the Congress building indigenous
marijuana farmers who have long grown
the plant illegally were hoping to
finally have a legal market for their
product
we are the victims of the war against
drugs there are many problems in our
territory armed Fighters forced
recruitment assassinations of indigenous
authorities a lot of conference station
and a lot of war that is why we want
this project to help the victims
and it was another loss for the
government of President Gustavo Petro
whose many ambitious social reforms have
encountered growing resistance in
Congress while recent scandals involving
close allies have affected his
popularity
on Tuesday tens of thousands of people
took to the streets in opposition to the
government reforms they see as a threat
to the country's democracy
everything worries me the labor reform
seems to me a massacre of businesses
many people are going to lose their jobs
they want to turn our health system into
a political Monopoly these reforms as
they are being presented are catastrophe
Tuesday also marked the end of the road
for Petro's labor reform in Congress
while the pension and health bills
managed to survive the current process
and will continue to be as discussed in
the next legislative period that starts
in August but with key Regional
elections coming up in October many here
believe that the government
transformative agenda will continue to
have a hard time moving forward